aquí en Río de Janeiro en la mayor parte
del país se vota hasta las 5 de la tarde
pero hay que recordar que Brasil es un
país inmenso donde hay cuatro usos
horarios habrá
577.000 urnas electrónicas para un poco
más de 156 millones de electores son de
hecho una de las elecciones más grandes
del mundo y la magia digamos de las
urnas electrónicas va a permitir conocer
en tiempos récord los resultados dos o
tres horas sabremos qué pasa en este
país donde incluso esas urnas se llegan
a país a ciudades pequeñas villarejos
que están en medio de la selva
amazónicas veis a mi espalda las colas
desde las 7 de la mañana hay gente
esperando son las elecciones más reñidas
desde que en Brasil acabó la dictadura
militar